i heard a record uh
you you played a record that wayne was
on
now you got wayne
to like wade was you know wayne knew
what it was when he got on the record
i'll just say that
shout out to wayne yeah was that a
record like we just talked about was
that like one of those records where you
you knew wayne was getting on it when
you cut it
actually no no i had already
i had already made that joint i had
already recorded it but i didn't finish
it it was just like the verse
was on my verse and
i had uh i think yo
um wayne has sent me the uh the russian
roulette joint
for his album and benny you know man
and um sent that [ __ ] back and whatever
and you know in the podcast then we did
the podcast
his uh you know yeah yeah yeah and you
know
man he he was like man y'all man i
appreciate y'all man y'all never need me
for anything
send it through y'all got something to
send it through i said oh yeah
don't don't tell me that yeah send
yourself uh
i'm saying it right now then i sent it
through
you know shout out my [ __ ] mac man man
my [ __ ] mac man
good dude man hey that [ __ ] happened man
that's my dog right there
shout out to wayne man that nigga's
incredible we did more [ __ ] too i got in
the studio with them [ __ ] on miami
we did some more so there's some other
[ __ ] so on a hard drive somewhere
man wayne got something crazy that's a
fact